to welcome everybody to HT HT podcast
I'm sure you all know that this has been
perhaps the most dramatic week of all
time and YouTube history things happened
that nobody could have predicted they've
all happened here this week we brought
all the T out as you can see Lipton's
finest I assure you that the entire
studio smells of Lipton's finest tea
room by the way is not a sponsor just a
fan it is very good to you so we're
gonna talk about all that stuff
obviously thank you to day to tushy
our wonderful beautiful sponsor and
before we start with the tea actually
you know a little current event T in our
own life one of our teddy fresh
employees tested positive for corona
virus and the last two days has been
totally insane of us trying to be like
holy [ __ ] like our life flashed before
our eyes
yeah because we've we when the virus hit
really hard we all started to work from
home but slowly it's really hard to not
actually work in the same space Dawn was
lifted I mean lockdown was lifted and
regardless we deal with it apparel you
need to see it in person you need to
design and review stuff in person so
I've been working with him pretty
closely and just a lot of people on our
team have been working with that person
pretty closely but we were wearing a
mask the whole time and Dan was was dan
you had a close encounter with him too
didn't you mmm-hmm yeah just they needed
some help in the teddy fresh office last
week to move some stuff around so I was
like moving heavy equipment with him
last week so when I already infected so
we were all freaking out and apparently
there's a new test actually called the
what is it called the antigen antigen
test which is amazing you it's a no swab
that go on your sinus which was
a whole weird phenomenon by itself but
they tell you the results in 15 minutes
you're so great but there's so many
people trying to do it like Ian how long
did you wait to get the test yesterday I
took me like six hours six hours pork
Ian was waiting to get because we all
had to make sure we were negative before
yeah otherwise we're like you know
wait so everybody is negative in a Teddy
fresh and in the podcast room we were
all wearing masks that is proof to you
guys where the mass they work seems so
we're still gonna be super cautious
because there is more chance of a false
negative you know a that's scary well I
was scary things new testing no I'm my
head in the sand to send a responsible
message out that even though we tested
negative we're still wearing masks out
here when we're together back there and
some of our people for example one of
our employee is going to quarantine
himself from his wife because she's in
danger he's high risk she's got asthma
so yeah it's it's serious it's dude when
when the corona virus comes into your
into your immediate circle right then
it's like oh my god I had this I was
like we can't work we have a babysitter
right she's not gonna be able to and
heard she has a high-risk dad so she so
we're all super careful for her so are
like okay she's not be able to come
around us we're not gonna have a
babysitter we're not to be able to go to
the office drunk to be able to work at
all cuz taking care of Theodore just
alone is like a full-time job we're too
[ __ ] we're just we're gonna be so
[ __ ] for the next month or whatever
two weeks that's just regardless of how
the virus is gonna affect you - right
and hopefully I don't die hopefully I
don't also die because let's face it I'm
morbidly obese that's a high risk factor
and I think that's enough I don't know
if I'm morbidly obese I don't think so
I'm obese and just if you're curious the
guy that tested positive
does not have symptoms yeah what oh yeah
he somebody told him he someone he knew
tested positive contact tracer yeah I
had a friend over yeah about twice and
then that friend told him she tested
positive oh that's when he went and
tested right away he was positive and I
will say congratulations to America for
smashing yet again The Daily Record I
think we got like fifty six thousand new
cases yesterday so really at this point
what can you really do except just watch
the world burn I mean what the [ __ ] can
we do at this point the country is
literally closing its borders to us the
world the world what did I say the
country yeah the what yes the world
nobody wants us cuz we're plagued we're
plague-ridden society to understand that
we have a plague here in the United
States that every other wealthy country
has now reopened their economy and
they're just they're they're good they
conquered it but we are plagued we are
plague inc you know that game we are the
epicenter of plague inc I don't know
what that's not a good analogy because
if this was a plague ain't the virus
would be doing poorly because it's just
infected the United States you know
don't you don't know that game play game
where you play as a virus you try to
kill all of humanity you guys never
played that for real I know of it I uh
it's so it's so fun it is actually a
really fun game sure you engineer a
virus and you're to give it the perfect
virility to wipe out humanity and and
you get to like upgrade certain aspects
like contagion faked like death fatality
like how deadly it is how it spreads and
you kind of got it because you don't
want it to be too deadly otherwise it
doesn't spread a lot right and so you
have to spend
your points carefully what kind of a
nerd thought about that game I don't
know but it's really fun I think that
game was developed in the whoo-ha uh
laboratory in China yes anyway that's
our update you know what else was
shocked the hell out of me was that I
just we showed up on John Oliver Papa
showed up on John Oliver let's pull this
up watch what just get claimed watch us
get claimed for showing our clip on his
show watch it happen don't just wanna do
this but they're gonna [ __ ] clancy
brown glynn promise yeah and he only
used that slur in the course of
explaining that he doesn't use it and
that's an argument he's tried to make
repeatedly like in this interview where
he attempts to prove that he's not a fan
of the n-word in the weirdest imaginable
way can i go to dinner somebody uses
that word one time don't say now get up
and we dinner then we have it we watch
this show regularly and well I didn't I
didn't people told me before I saw it
people are like you're on John Oliver
and I was like I was like I open a good
way I don't need none all they're
putting me on blast
here's this youtuber age three giving
pup John an n-word pass or some crazy
[ __ ]
who knows that turns me on yeah let's
watch this again he's saying let's see
what is his point here what is he trying
to say about papa
he just imaginable can I go to dinner
somebody uses that word one time don't
say the word and I'll get up and leave
dinner I've done that response cuz I
remember he goes he went if I go to
dinner to someone and they used the
n-word one time and I'll leave yeah and
I said I don't I don't usually go to
dinner with people that say the n-word
so I was hoping you would exclude that
but you know what Papa's Papa is just
trying to clear his name here and let's
see what John Oliver's point is Bert
yeah nothing says I'm not a racist
repeatedly making dinner plans with
people who might say the n-word that's
my joke you [ __ ]
they watched the podcast took my joke
and cut it out once they do in fact say
it I didn't realize there was a more
repulsive type of Papa John's dinner
than this Cummings but it does your even
know anything about pizza you've Creasy
[ __ ] em all Pete is actually very
nutritious that's propaganda did I say
anything offensive do I need to back it
up I'm only at I'm only saying coming
from a dude from England I'm a friend of
John Oliver so watch it I just don't
think he's in the right to talk [ __ ] on
Papa John Pizza I just don't think it's
right and I got to stand up for my boy
especially when they're gonna steal my
joke cut me I ass out wait wait wait
wait I thought we resolved this though
and that Papa John's has fallen off a
cliff in terms of quality because
there's a pizza grading system and if
you look at that that looks like a
pretty good pie that looks like I'm not
seeing even spread you see all those
cracks where you can see the sauce
popping well it's kind of like the
picture it's like a bad end pixels he's
going all the way up to look at the
bottom left of that pizza you see the
cheese move all the way up to the corner
not a great pot I would eat that right I
wouldn't eat that right now roof of that
I think Papa will give that a 7 out of
10
I love pizza and I love people that's a
pre it almost sounds like he eats people
go ahead play it again I love pizza and
I love people he eats people now we love
Papa here friend of the show obviously
but I would I think that's a
good-looking pizza and I'm not gonna get
stuck on this for too long okay let's
move on
so okay but there's so much drama to
cover so there's dr. disrespects who was
completely and forever banned from
twitch okay that's one there Shane
Dawson V Tati V jeffree star read the
world v the world v family came down on
Shane Dawson and then James Charles is
just I think James Charles is just
Kermit the Frog with T he's like he is
Kermit the Frog from that meme you know
what I mean because he's literally just
chillin back yeah yeah and then there's
there's another one oh and then our our
friend of the show Chris D'Elia Wow
that okay so before I start talking
about the drama I want to say this
emphatically okay keep me in check
you look as we talk about these because
these are people I think on the culture
of Internet today and I'm guilty of
doing this myself we tend to see people
as villains and heroes and the amount of
hate and vitriol and just the amount of
[ __ ] you can throw on somebody is just
so is so harmful and toxic that we have
to remember that the people we're
talking about today although it's a very
polarized and serious situations are
people okay and then there was another
loss this week too right there was a
brain ela there was a twitch streamer
that tragically took his life he was
like a big wild player I I wasn't
familiar with him but Dan
I know dance had told me he was quite
familiar with them is that right Dan uh
no I didn't follow him or anything I
knew of him though because yeah he was
he's been in the while community for as
long as I can remember I've been hearing
about him so yeah but to be honest I'm
not super familiar enough to know why or
what happened but
but I know like he I think it was
another issue of you know mental mental
illness people were saying he was
bipolar and and it's like people in the
inner are just so [ __ ] cruel you know
he tweeted out something about his
ex-girlfriend him six months ago I don't
think we said his name reckful yeah
wreck falls Thank You Miriam and his
name is Byron yes he tweeted out
something to his ex-girlfriend being
like I want to marry you and people were
like clowning on him
now obviously you can't boil down
someone's I mean I don't think that I
don't know enough let's say to just to
know how much something like that
actually contributed to his suicide so
I'm not gonna make that claim but what I
can't say is that people are so [ __ ]
cruel online and I think I'm just so and
again this might come off as
hypocritical because I've definitely
thrown a lot of [ __ ] and shared all over
the place but it's just so some people
are just so [ __ ] cruel man myself
included I guess I don't know I don't
know but I'm gonna talk about this stuff
and I'm gonna try to be as as humanizing
as possible of the people we're talking
about right and that's important so the
first one doctor disrespect Titan of
twitch
I think after ninja and who's the Shroud
they both went to mixer right and twitch
was probably one of the top definitely
seems to be having the biggest name
recognition on twitch he even did this
he signed a multi-year contract with
them he made this huge did you see this
video they made together was like some
epic [ __ ] skydiving I mean I mean this
just came out right like a month or two
or recently yeah I was a couple months
ago I see doctor disrespect twitch
banner or ad well you call that [ __ ] it
would be commercial
yeah here it is he this is like the most
epic should I ever fought and did he
just came out so they were all in on Doc
they were investigating I mean this is
like a high-end production think I'm a
small baby
[Music]
dude that's like super high-end heard of
a power I agree I think it's funny too
good
wait video
[Music]
why are we giggling the bow gentleman I
still play games to play games
[Music]
I dominate did it shot really long years
ago I started my hotshot gaming career
in a small room that old 1817 desk my
mom gave me $300 hewlett-packard
computer everyone has a tree purpose of
life I'm at the tippity-top in the
mountain
love and peak condition and I'm not even
in shape
do you realize someday that every man
must decide
if that starts streaming but you know
the biggest difference between me and
you boy
[Music]
[Music]
it's a great first of all it's great
everybody loved it it's crazy they
probably spent that's sick that's a sick
ad dude only on Twitter look at that
that's it go come that's like a Super
Bowl ad yeah
so they made so they produce this you
know in partnership with him a mere you
know few months ago in March mid-march
so what did something happen and just
out of nowhere it was announced that he
is permanently forever banned from
twitch banned banned and then and they
even refunded people for their right
which is I think was unusual because
people were like what happened to my
refund and people were like oh you'll
get to use the emojis till the end of
the month no twitch refunded everybody
closed his channel and then were there
not sponsors that also dropped him or
what happened with that there's been
some back-and-forth I saw that some of
them it seemed like in the in like
initial moments after the ban was
announced took down stuff with his face
on and everything but then they it was
reversed later which kind of adds
another weird element to all the
speculation
you know people wondering if the brands
were able to find out what happened and
it's not that bad and that's why they
put it back up or whatever it's
specifically not G fuel but like another
gamer energy drink thing that he had a
sponsorship with they they had taken him
down off their Twitter and everything
CNG fields website let me look I don't
it's not G fuel it same fuel game fuel
yo G fuel just got a free plug so game
fuel is he on there here yeah I just
went it pulled it up their Twitter feed
Mountain it's just act game fuel he's
their banner image and I guess they had
taken that banner image down but then
put it back up so made from that what
you will
wait this is a mountain to drink yeah
yeah yeah
slide out and do I don't see him on
their own page are you on their Twitter
or on their website I'm talking I'm on
their website talk about on their
Twitter okay let's go to teams I wanna
see if he's on their website or on the
yeah yeah he's got a deal oh go right
here
streaming partners doctor disrespect so
they haven't purged him but the thing is
that twitch put so twitch has not said
why at which is so bizarre
they've only put out a statement and
said as is our process we take
appropriate action but we have evidence
that a streamer has acted in violation
of our Community Guidelines or Terms of
Service these apply to all streamers
regardless of status or prominence in
the community what's happening out there
Dan or is that our neighbor he went to
go get coffee
oh just made a weird noise so so how
long has it been by the way is it like a
full week no what um let's see
yeah I think the band it was last Friday
so exactly a week ago so it's been a
week twitch has not explained and then
doc the doc put out a tweet saying I
don't know why they haven't said
anything to me and everybody there's
just crazy speculation as to what's
going on and so so you should read this
to it where is this Twitter let's see
frustrating because you want me read his
tweet it says champions club twitch has
not notified me on the specific reason
behind their decision firm handshakes to
all who support me during this difficult
time doctor disrespect that was on June
27th I mean I wanted you to read it
because I feel like even his tweet is
kind of not honest in a way of they
haven't notified him he's saying like
they haven't told me why doesn't mean I
said no why
yeah it doesn't mean he's not
speculating or Liz Huff aware of what
happened or I just feel like there's no
reason for this situation to be so
mysterious that's it's it's truly one of
the most bizarre things
all time eally you made a really good
analogy last night when we were talking
about it yes because about my
professional team I've been getting
pretty frustrated with the situation
because I just think it's irresponsible
for someone as big as twitch to make
such a big move and not say why and it's
been a week now and everyone is
speculating and speculating and the fact
that I haven't said why it makes
everyone think that it must be a super
bad action he raped a kid I don't know
everyone is thinking like the worst
thing possible or immediate I think a
lot of people think it's a me-too thing
because it came in the mists of all that
no one knows but yes there's a million
raping a kid whoa the worst right now
and the fact that they haven't even put
a little tiny bit of statement to stop
all the speculations which is
irresponsible on their part what I said
to you last night was like can you
imagine saying that in any other big
field I don't think so like if a big
football player was removed from his
team all of a sudden in what world do
you think no one would say why like and
not even like a one sentence statement
saying like this may have happened we're
looking into it or I don't know it would
be it would be outrageous and but it
would be it would never happen and it's
a really good analogy and then the other
thing that perplexes me is that there's
not been any leaks like there's a couple
of I was a couple of tweets of people
speculating that they know but not
saying anything specifically how is it
that nobody has leaked this information
it's so bizarre at least so so I so what
I'm gonna do now is speculate what could
these things mean okay so let me show
you some tweets of people who claimed to
be in the know there's this guy slasher
okay he is a eSports reporter and I
think he's seen as as being credible
[Music]
he's broken a lot of stories and I and I
think people people believe his
reporting so he said he first responded
to doctor disrespect he said
food-for-thought twitch does not issue
specific reasons to streamers for
permanent bans method Josh was banned
following a report of sexual assault and
to which never commented publicly or
privately Josh and I suppose I damn were
told other Terms of Service violations
so he's so he I think what he's implying
is that they're not gonna tell you so
doc statement doesn't really mean
anything or I don't know I find it
sounds like there is a precedent for
them no but they are their partner with
that guy they owe him an explanation yes
and everyone I find it irresponsible and
unprofessional but that kind of goes to
what we've kind of been saying about
twitch for a while is that to me having
worked with them and seeing how they
operate from the inside and how they
responded when we left their program
they're kind of they're just they're
just really drama and it's a bunch of
young people running the show and I just
I mean the first of all that my partner
managers I don't want to I don't want to
they were super nice and super
professional the two people that managed
us personally they were amazing but it
seems like the structure of the come
it's just doesn't seem like a well-run
company it doesn't it just doesn't so I
don't know if this is probably
symptomatic of that but who knows
keemstar put out the first conspiracy
theory of course and this in my opinion
is probably the dumbest woman and not
just because Kim stood oh I saw this and
I mean either roll my eyes it's like a
[ __ ] Q and aankhen fortune yeah it's
not a conspiracy well he put it forward
I mean I immediately read it I was like
that is the most implausible dumb [ __ ]
everybody garbage
he's a apparently dog shroud and ninja
were in talks on launching a new
streaming platform first of all doc and
Ninja don't get along why would they be
in talk stream just launched a new
streaming platform were approached by
spot
five under Google this modifying google
associated ah not to my knowledge so
what the [ __ ] does that even make sense
from the beginning in order to suck what
a pro yes I mean maybe I'm wrong I don't
think I don't know yeah I'm almost
certain they're not but let's check that
under Google in order to sign contracts
and launch in the coming weeks on
Spotify as soon to be announced a
streaming service do you understand how
stupid this sounds already Spotify is
all the sudden becoming a streaming
service doc reportedly approached
multiple streamers personally on twitch
in order to facilitate that's like
that's not what it means it means a new
streaming platform that's probably a
part of Spotify on Spotify soon okay to
be announced so anyway he's been he's
conspiring to make a streaming platform
doc report approached multiple streamers
personally on twitch in order to
facilitate a platform switch twitch
found out about it as a result legal
team completely terminated its contract
and it's currently filing motions for
civil suits both dog twitch and Spotify
are currently undergoing mediation no
one can talk or discuss this due to NDA
is imposed by Google
twitch is still twitches of going full
damage trouble attempting to drag Google
and to lawsuits in order to prevent or
taint their launch this will all be
filed Monday well Monday came and went
yeah
by the way all this people who say that
they can't say anything because it's a
legal matter I don't understand that and
what kind of a legal case or lawsuit or
legal NDA when have you seen a case
where you can't even say what it's about
or like even its light the most general
description of what it's about
so let me try to address that let me
show some of the tweets of people for
suppose who have made credible
speculations that's just stupid
conspiracy theories yet Spotify has no
association with Google did you confirm
that like um you know it doesn't look
like they directly own them but I am
seeing an article from April last year
Google slash alphabet acquiring Spotify
in forty three billion dollar cash
witty deal so maybe there is some
association there I was not aware of
that but where is it I know I this is
just some like random website though I'm
not nothing listed okay so here's the
first one
this girl Shannon who she tweeted this
out
like immediately following the
announcement and I think I could be
speaking out of turn but I recall her
working she used to work at twitch but
she's definitely a streamer
she definitely has association with
twitch she says from my own sources doc
is indeed done and not just on twitch I
know why and cannot say but this is
serious and people started saying wool
if you know if you can't say then why
did you bother tweeting it if you be
work saying are you just trying to get
attention for yourself like what's the
point of this sweep but it so so let's
say hypothetically let's assume the
worst right like she's implying what is
she implying that he I think what she's
implying is that he has a credible
allegation of some kind of me to thing
if that was the case the wouldn't which
say an allegation was brought to our
attention for that reason he's been and
we're looking into it so I was thinking
I've been trying to Rack my brain why
would they do that my thing is like I
think they just want to avoid any
responsibility one way or the other
they're trying to have the cake and eat
it too right that's not okay which isn't
a good politics just not a fair policy
they're thinking if we ban him and it
turned let's say let's say he's accused
of rape and they say if we ban him and
he's exonerated a year later we're gonna
look like the biggest [ __ ] and and
probably we can even sue us because we
have this partnership I don't think so
if they put a legitimate effort into
looking into it and do a legitimate
investigation into the allegation if
they do when they come with results then
they have all the power to follow with
according to the
so what if I think it's worse right now
for a doc because what if it's not as
bad as everyone is thinking
yeah then everyone in their mind is
already thinking oh a dog is that guy
but them probably rapes him what could
be bad enough that they would
permanently Seban like one of their
biggest partners who by the way is a
massive pull for to the platform like
he's a huge attraction I don't know and
it's not our job to speculate but just
guesses the other thing that I'm
thinking about twitch trying to
understand what they're doing is let's
say there's these credible accusations
against him so if they don't drop him
then they're afraid of being like Oh
twitch knew they so like a reporter goes
oh we have evidence to twitch new for
this X amount of time and didn't act
that's why they're okay to drop him
right now right while they're looking
into it but they should they need to
properly look into it and investigate
well then the other thing is like like
that like slasher said it's their policy
to not state a reason so maybe they're
just abiding by that it didn't say
because he says they won't he didn't say
it he says they did something they don't
do he said they didn't specifically say
in the past but it was following a
sexual allegation so it sounds like
there was already context out there
based on what he said yeah I opened that
tweet again he said following an
allegation they dropped someone and they
didn't specify mm-hmm
I don't understand how there's not more
public information about it don't only
so that's so anyway that this pretty
much is like one of the big things out
there they were actually at 30 minutes
if we want to take a quick break so let
me just finish my point here I'm thank
you for the reminder yeah I thought it
was a sound bite of Pharrell that's the
real deal but I kept digging on this I
it doesn't look like it looks like a
pore I'm sorry Google was thinking about
modify last year or something but it
doesn't look like I feel like I feel
like if there was any association they
would have I would know that there's
like they're always like we've got all
these opportunities with all these
companies we own mm-hmm and wait Spotify
is buying podcasts from YouTube hello
the Joe Rogan that was like a huge story
they were like Spotify bought it that's
not related to live streaming well yeah
but he's saying that there's something
ok whatever I'm over it
as a stupid conspiracy theory yeah
you're focusing on the part that so
theory the firt you know what let's take
a break and we'll dig in a little deeper
because I'm never gonna get out of this
so we'll be right back after this quick
commercial break
you poop you wash you dry it's a
three-step process Toshi is in the
business of ass blasting with water
everyone has an ass everybody everybody
has an ass
everyone deserves the gift of touchy
wiping your butt with dry toilet paper
does not remove all the [ __ ] this is the
actual copy is awesome I love tushy if
you poop on any other part of your body
would you just wipe it off with dry
paper no but I wouldn't I don't see
myself pooping anywhere else on the body
but good analogy if we got poop on any
other part of your body yeah I like a
better poop on your other part of your
body but would you wipe it off a dry
paper hell no water cleans better than
dry paper it's just that simple let's be
frank here thankfully there's now a
sleek bidet attachment that clips onto
your existing toilet and sprays your
buck ompletely clean with fresh water
and it's called tushy was the best thing
you could do for your butt till she
sprays directly to your ass it removes
the poop completely so you aren't
sitting on bacteria that leads to nasty
things like hemorrhoids yeast infections
UTIs itchy [ __ ] add skid marks but
days are common and the rest of the
world it's time us in America catch the
[ __ ] up I'm just going to drop an f-bomb
because they say [ __ ] in there but it's
true it's disgusting here's wiping
[ __ ] your [ __ ] let's get it clean
good enough to eat right you know yeah
here's the other thing but but day saves
you money on toilet paper
you know toilet paper is surprisingly
expensive that should say it's you back
I mean am I like you go there you get a
you get a packet oh baby like 30 [ __ ]
dollars I'm I it's expensive am I wrong
I've always been surprised by how
expensive toilet paper is back me up but
it's like 15 bucks for like 30 rolls me
it sets you back it's like a big-ticket
item at the grocery store
there's nobody backing me up here you
guys are all square as hell
nobody crickets toilet papers expect yes
yes it's very faint o'clock no leave it
in insolence wait you guys don't agree
the toilet paper is expensive it's not
$30 I liked back that up I'm serious
like Bill Gates saying yeah cause it's
like 15 bucks for 30 rolls isn't it I
don't know that it's even 15 you getting
that Kirkland brand what are you getting
you bought in bulk yeah yeah Kirkland
brand well whatever I don't know I just
bio-vipers I'm divided by the palette
I'm not a $10 you guys really trying to
make me into Bill Gates $30 sounded like
close already hold on toilet paper let's
do a name brand like Charmin Charmin
it's a good brand good stuff that's a
good look [ __ ] 24 oh it's all sold
out look at this 24 rolls don't come and
1/8 $8
12-pack of Charmin ultra CBS 13 bucks
$13 but this is a supreme Roldan that's
like some little [ __ ] well you gotta
get the Kirkland brand to play
okay fine Kirkland brand to now go and
we're like Target to really okay my
target the funk keep all this end should
all be part of that well what the [ __ ]
are they advertising what is it here
Sharman's the good [ __ ] okay this is the
real [ __ ] 12 [ __ ] rolls they're here
they always [ __ ] well here dollar
per roll that's 12 rolls I said if you
buy like a 24 pack it's like 30 bucks
and it can be while y'all acting like
I'm so at it how much for the 30 mega 30
bucks what a dollar all why you wise
what I want any other time
toilet paper wait time because what I'm
at the point is you're paying with the
dollar a roll that's pretty expensive
even for 12 rolls
why should I'm just saying it has always
struck me that toilet paper so expensive
because they're acting like I'm Bill
Gates do you use - I thought you don't
use to look there I didn't always have a
bidet Zack these baby wipes before that
so what I suffer perspective about
toilet paper hey by the way can we talk
about how they [ __ ] 30 rolls equals
120 rolls
shut up and 30 wrong it's the roll yeah
but nobody sells rupal roll its
quadruple like this roll is 20 times the
fries are wrong behind Quan roll is like
getting a 20 pack you guys need to
apologize
there's owe me an apology I'm waiting
it's I'm not apologizing because you
didn't specify the amount when you said
$30 for toilet paper I was like dude
yeah 500 rolls of toilet paper but I
like to stop be expensive well I like to
stop okay but can we agree the toilet
papers expensive you guys gonna give me
that the real estate in our apartment
for for 500 rolls it was you guys not
you guys don't dispute that toilet paper
is expensive right now to me on record I
remembered that it used to seem
expensive does when we were super broke
and we had like no money do why you
gotta make a like a class issue I'm just
speaking for the people a dollar or all
yes what what brand do you guys buy I
made something equivalent to this you
know go get that Kirkland - plus you're
obsessed with Kirkland - Blood I [ __ ]
love cost codes read on the ass okay how
much is Kirkland I'm hoping in that
people out there the point is that like
you know you're spending $30 a month it
was you have a family I don't I'd you
know
that [ __ ] will last you morning I never
took I never kept track of how much
toilet paper you so I actually don't
know how much to go through a month like
to do it yeah and unless you a few
months I think
you don't buy toilet paper every time
you look you go to the grocery store you
spend about a hundred bucks and I'm and
then it's always like dude like 30% of
this was [ __ ] on toilet paper denial
[Laughter]
and the paper towels is a whole nother
thing it's like oh great you know 50% of
my hundred-dollar bills
toilet paper and a 30 pack of Kirkland
two-ply is $20 boom that's pretty
expensive it's not 30 I think that's a
deal man of course there's a range dude
you're talking about curtain with
two-ply that's like the [ __ ] bottom
wrong you know what I will but it's
Costco you need a membership to buy a
new plug even including the cost of
membership you have to include the cost
of membership really wonder what does he
have to say I don't know the paper adds
up we shifted back to our sponsor real
quick I will agree with you that baby
wipes are expensive baby wipes he's out
Zach now it's just everybody's muted
damn
listen there's a commonality we all
agree the toilet paper doesn't clean
properly and it's way too expensive with
tushie you don't have to have to buy
toilet paper again okay you could still
use a little bit they give you
permission they says you can use a
little bit to pat yourself dry but that
amount is negligible so that $30 pack is
gonna be ending up lasting you maybe a
decade and guess what it won't clog your
toilets either
Zach talking about baby wipes how dare
you devastate our environment
till she sprays your ass with fresh
water it's not toilet water till she
connects to the water supply behind your
toilet to spray your dirty parts with
clean fresh water it's the same water
you brush your teeth with wet wipes are
worse than toilet paper they're terrible
for the environment if you don't believe
me Google fatberg you will get it and
they also cause anal fissures which
don't Google that by the way you don't
want anal fissures guess what Toshi is
only 79 bucks mmm that's 79 bucks that
pays in dividend you pay that off and
like I don't know a month depending on
how much you [ __ ] how many people in
your family what's an investment 79
bucks won't I'm not buying toilet paper
mmm it's like a four to six days
dividends they also have an ottoman that
helps you get everything out you put
your feet up it's like a sexy tooth or
cloud you put your feet up and it helps
you poop it's also only $69 very nice
SoCo - hello - she calm / h3h3 and get
10% off your order guys please support
our sponsor because let's face it
they're the only one left
so please go - hello tisha calm / h3h3
for 10% off your order
[Laughter]
all right welcome back so the first
theory is that there's some kind of
criminal something in nature witches
would apparently explain why everyone so
hush-hush if it's so sensitive because
let's face it also let's face it like
you if you are the first person to talk
then everyone's gonna like if it's a
criminal matter and and then it's with
everyone like everybody who works for
twitch is being instructed you cannot
leak this let's say this girl Shannon
goes he did this and I know from a
source they're gonna investigate that so
I think if if it is so serious then I
guess people who are really afraid of
the consequences of being the person to
have leaked that information but you
could leak it anonymously so easily just
to anybody I don't get it
the second theory I mean just think of
any other like all the events that we
saw happen during the me to movement
there wasn't any like mysterious no
dropping someone out because of an
allegation they say very clearly what
delegation is and that they're looking
into it yeah and there were cases where
they decided that delegation was not
anything warranting you know dropping
the person I think the only reason
people are assuming it's a me-too thing
is because it came right in the mitts of
this big wave of me to against like
twitch streamers specifically but you
see that's another reason why twitches
is if it's not a me two twitches doing
him so dirty that's mine that's how
irresponsible they're doing him so dirty
but he must he whatever he did he must
have [ __ ] them hard because I know
they're spiteful because when we went
when we went back to YouTube they
immediately dropped us from the partner
program and they still owed us money I
was like hey can you guys pay me though
it you have to reset up for the partner
program first
to pay you I was like [ __ ] you they they
are spiteful that's why I call it high
school drama yeah
but going back to his tweet from his
side I also don't get it because if if
he doesn't know what happened you would
think he would be on water a lot more
like hey what's up what's yeah outraged
and his yeah that's a really good point
too because his tweet was very cordial
like hey guys yeah we don't know what's
going on but thanks for stick with me if
it was me and I really didn't have any
suspicions and I didn't know and I knew
I didn't do anything wrong in it I'd be
like yeah what the [ __ ] would demand
answers but nothing everybody's silent
and even if you're taking legal action
that doesn't mean you can't talk about
it you would still be vote well about it
I'm gonna stop you there lawyers always
say don't speak publicly on the case
because it can be used against you
lawyers alway advise their clients to
not speak publicly always certain degree
I think always not to say that he can't
say a word about it that's actually
harming him so that's well maybe it's
harming him right now but it might be
helpful to his legal case to not say
anything it is very possible that
lawyers if there's a legal dispute going
on which is very likely that his lawyers
would say would tell him do not say
anything publicly yes that is uh that's
the most likely explanation now what I
think is what I found the most
interesting and weirdly plausible
explanation is if you look at his final
stream people have been scrutinizing his
last stream before he was banned he ends
it by talking about some really crazy
conspiracy theories I had no idea he was
into it turns out the doc is into 5g
coronavirus [ __ ] apparent now Dan or in
or anyone back there
people were memeing on Doc for having
these weird like pyramids or all around
his house to to prevent 5g Corona waves
is that real yeah he loves a shun guy
shun guy rocks but is that so
that a meme or is he really trying to
prevent Corona it's hard to tell with
his whole persona but but the whole
being afraid of 5g giving you Corona it
to me doesn't really jive with the whole
persona
so it seems legit yeah I can't really
say for sure so I think it is legit
because here he calls out a known
conspiracy theorist called David Icke
and this guy Austin I heard by the way
what's that this David Icke guy is a
Holocaust denier that's what I was
getting to this guy he's one of these
conspiracy theorists who so deep down
the rabbit hole he like if there's a
conspiracy he believes in it okay he
believes in the 5g coronavirus [ __ ]
he believes in lizard people literally
he believes he's a Holocaust denier
people have speculated that he thinks
lizard people is an analogy for Jews I
swear to God I mean just go to his
Wikipedia page and read up on this guy
he is a [ __ ] date he's a he's of the
click he's a kook I mean that's putting
it mildly
so the doc so the doc gives a very
sincere and strange shout out to him and
his final moments of twitch and I can
and for example if I look at YouTube's
policy they're very sensitive about
these kinds of misinformation that's
very important right now also owned by
Amazon who is rivals of Facebook Mark
Zuckerberg and Jeff Bezos I stopped
following what I was saying wait is I
think I lost I think I lost some sauces
let me start off I just became Charlie
from I think they're hitting this with
the with the 5g I think what I was
meaning to say is that there's a big
push right now to prevent misinformation
on social media platforms YouTube
Facebook Twitter are all taking her
stances Facebook is not Facebook is
starting to get there being boycotted or
trying today no there no they are
because literally like they're having
their own ad pocalypse on Facebook right
now okay because they're not doing
anything to stop ya [ __ ] like this and
so Jeff Bezos is what it's getting to
who is in the same stratosphere as all
these people right
he owns twitch he owns Amazon I think
they're taking a hard I think this is
the most plausible theory they saw this
and they're taking a super hard stance
about spreading this information which
which I believe is that why would all
that what's with all the mystery because
they're [ __ ] a terrible Lee run
company and from what I understand this
isn't the first time that he's promoted
these kind of conspiracy
when did he I was reading that he's done
it on stream before so it I think you're
right Ethan that this this does seem the
most plausible that he was perhaps on
thin ice already like they had warned
him about not talking about this and so
and then he did it again and so they
banned him but I agree you late I they
should say that it's you know which is
like oh it's just another day we want
you we're sending messages from people
who are not even youtubers don't even
follow YouTube or twitch in general
asking like hey what's with this dog guy
it's like the biggest mystery of the
year and when we're now anyone who's
heard the doc the second thought that
they have in their head is like oh you
must have raped someone it's great
people are gonna look really dumb when
it finds it when it's just like he's a
conspiracy theorist and he's promoting
dumb [ __ ] that's a far cry yeah I mean
yeah I mean the thing is though that the
these people that seem to be implying
that they're in the know like the girl
you were talking about in the slasher
guy I mean they though they haven't come
out and say it I would say it's fair
that they've heavily implied that it's
more on the insidious side yeah they
agree I mean don't they look like real
dumbasses if it was the one I'm trying
to find the one that slasher wrote he's
implied that
he's working on the story and it's
really bad I'm trying to find it here
maybe this is it wanted to show this
tweet before I why it can I not find
this tweet it's one of the slasher ones
yeah
I'll put it maybe this is it I think he
erased in someone's screenshot it here
for several hours now I've been told
from credible sources the reason for his
band however due to the importance and
sensitivity around the subject I have
refrained from going on it I don't feel
comfortable with it currently that
implies something truly terrible same as
Shannon was saying right yeah and then
later he was on there's a pretty popular
twitch podcast called a train wrecked or
whatever you know I'm talking about
anyways that that he went on and he
seemed to he still wasn't saying
anything but the read the the between
the lines message again seemed to be
that it was something pretty dark so in
a vacuum if I if these people weren't
saying this I would assume it's this but
let's watch this clip and you guys tell
me what you think
I was watching uh Josh you just put it
on just chat and Jaime like I kind of
wanted to get off but now I don't want
to get off this is his final moments on
Twitter this is the last thing he ever
broadcast I was watching that Dyke
documentary on uh what's this guy Ike
Ike IC ke
older gentleman
[Music]
stealing he's sitting there anybody know
who I'm talking about first name to chat
David Icke yes Alex yes I like them even
if like it's it's like it just kind of
you know rather than this it's on
Netflix I believe it's on Netflix or is
it Amazon it's one of the - it's either
Amazon or Netflix a little documentary
on him it's pretty enlightening also it
allows you to do is just sort of like
you know allows you to step outside of
the box just a little bit I for one
don't want a bunch of his fans going and
learning about concealed not true not
whatever I don't know what's in that
though is I don't want to say that that
he's promoting that again I didn't got
it just be fair okay you're not
promoting Holocaust denial right I don't
know what's in that that documentary you
watched either look it up it looks like
it is on Amazon everything's on Amazon
bro you're pretty ironic that he got
banned for so wait can you read this
obnoxious of that well it sounds it does
it's it says the first authorized
documentary exploring the life of famed
conspiracy theorist David Icke the
madman who has been proven right again
and I okay that's the synopsis on Amazon
and written and directed by David Icke
not directed but he is in it so you know
that is great there yeah
he goes on that goes into these trances
I don't know I guess he's just reading
good I actually bought the uh mrs.
Sasson bought the book actually not me I
shouldn't take the credit she's staring
at me right now with the blade saying I
did I can't tell what character or like
having a mental break like this people
were reading into this very heavily yeah
yeah he knew he was Beth Lee band and
that's why you seen
oh yeah there at the very end what else
I'll skip to the end because he gets a
text and it seems like he got bad news
about something but I found this more
interesting than that that part could be
overtopped but let me skip to the end
and or did it not already happen no yeah
the part at the very end right here no
you know the part where people think
that he got the message with bad news
happens prior to yeah I think it already
happened because I the clip I saw he
like what okay it's this dream on stream
hold on what's that
roblox I knew it roblox I think we're
off topic we're going into roblox so
wait where do I find the part where he
is it in this very same where did you
get the bad news it I mean you'd have to
watch the whole thing I don't know the
exact time about here somewhere in back
there the timestamp me so
so these are these are the the
conspiracies and I don't know what to
make of it other than I think the one
thing we can conclude from it is that
twitch is a poorly run company but iiiii
it's the craziest thing ever
it's at 2:09 no just cores no no not
open no I'm just telling you from the
comments it's at 209 oh good alright 209
this is apparently when everyone was
watching very it has to happen
he pulls his phone out he's reading a
text and they say right there
he's luck whole demeanor has changed
suddenly
that's where we started watch me take
over I love it man see the
self-confidence in the chat that's what
I'm talking about the the
self-confidence of the champions club
it's at an all-time high and don't ever
stop please don't ever stop you got to
be strong in this world man
I was watching uh-oh I mean like I I
mean this whole thing is just so bizarre
it's hard to tell because you could
either just really be way looking into
it more than you should right you know
or he really has acting weird here I
can't jump captivated by you know what's
crazy is that because of all the beauty
guru drama it's kind of like somehow
somehow been overshadowed but I cannot
[ __ ] wait to find out what actually
happened I can't wait I saw this great
meme it was a wife and him to you rather
than show it he's always really funny
there's a wife and a husband in bed the
husband has turned away from the wife
deep in thought and the wife says I
wonder what he's thinking about and what
he's thinking about you know she thinks
he's like thinking about another woman
or something I've [ __ ] it up Freddie
no what's he thinking like I was
thinking about why don't you save you
the memes yeah send me the Matt you
should have done that one well I was
pulling it up as soon as you started
talking but I'm not
discordant oh my god open it what a
disaster so I mean I'm not gonna I'm not
making a conclusion what were the other
I hope for the best I mean I hope that
the worst isn't true and I hope the end
it but I don't know what it means for
for doc like what is he gonna do now I
guess you can stream anywhere else well
lucky for you because we're incredibly
unlucky
we'll probably find out right after we
finished recording this part yes so
where we publish it tomorrow
you know and this will all be moot well
let's look at this really cool meme
before we move on
that's not cuz I don't even know what
the [ __ ] going on here I heard Dan
sent it to me okay here's a cool meme
regarding the issue with Doc her I bet
he's thinking about other women me why
is it the tenses are weird her and me
should be him no no it's from his no
it's from his from his perspective her
my she is really good her I bet he's
thinking about other women but he how is
he simultaneously thinking about what
she's thinking about when he's thinking
about something entirely different
we are looking at this from the
third-person perspective we are not
looking at this from his perspective
well it's just I mean him what the hell
happened to doctor disrespect identify
what this meme heavily all right can I
get some what are the stones resolved on
a man I need some sugar night some shoe
guy what is shoe guy that's a great
question alright thank you for the
answer I think we might uh get banned if
we talk black lustrous non-crystalline
mineraloid consisting of more than 98
weight 98 weight percent of carbon sugar
and and does it say say anything about
its frequency oh that's a good question
does it have the same frequency as 5g I
don't see anything about Hertz megahertz
gigahertz any sort of Hertz here in the
Wikipedia article about it but that's
probably because it's being censored by
the NWO so are we ready to move on to
Shane Dawson
shane dawson is in what can only be
described as Logan Paul
he's in a Logan Paul exile you know what
Napoleon you know ever went to pulling
on waged war on your all of Europe and
they sent him to an island they don't
want to kill him because they respected
him too much
they just exiled him from all of Europe
they sent is asked to an island
what was that island called remember oh
I don't remember the name they sent him
to an island bro that's what they did to
shame they like you are exiled from
YouTube all three I have never seen this
happen to anyone since Logan Paul filmed
the corpse in the forest elbow elbow
elbow elbow yeah
wait isn't that where the Spanish people
party now for that that's a betta elbow
it's close I wonder what goes on hell
but these days that's a good question
yeah maybe we should throw a rave there
and the whole story of Napoleon on Elba
is crazy he tried to come back
it was crazy come back he tried yeah but
it didn't worries do another yeah you
know here is another arm yeah but he got
honed didn't he swim back wasn't that is
definitely not I can tell you as someone
who has a very poor understanding of
everything that he did not swim back let
me probe deeper here Napoleon swam from
a island and an exile Island to France
and then raised the army oh my god did
no I think somebody ed let's let's let's
get back on Shane you were looking that
up he didn't swim come on who would get
it I want to know if you swim no I think
he swam dude no he did it
okay look it up no he was definitely
someone came a night and picked them up
in all this [ __ ] but you don't swim
like a hundred miles if you're just some
dude
kela are you able to find anything about
Napoleon swimming there's a wall of text
here side tries to just
ctrl-f swim and swim then come on there
just say didn't a boy and swim bro yeah
are you [ __ ] with me did Napoleon
swim from Elba our European fans how did
Napoleon escape from Elba
you ready Zack it's gonna be swimming
dude it says he swam sixty miles at 260
kilometers away from the French [ __ ]
border dude he's straight pure willpower
he just did it just made it happen
but so what happens when he gets on the
on the coast after his crazy swim he
just goes really raises an army just go
to the British water lily exactly anyway
Napoleon swam Napoleon was the greatest
swimmer ever Shane [ __ ] that's so
sidetracked so Shane is exiled like
Napoleon is what I was meaning to say
either what are you typing so furiously
you think you're in this the swimming
Khalid he came with a ball and picked
this up at night probably I'm seeing the
Elba Island is not far it's a high and I
told you it's 150 miles you swam people
swim from have you because I hope yeah
do you know how far Alcatraz is from San
Francisco I don't know look up the
distance okay tell me the distance and
remember Elba is 150 miles it's
definitely not under 50 miles you can
you could skip the looking up its
not a hundred and fifty miles don't tell
me the distance of Alcatraz half a mile
half a mile zach 4.6 miles might as well
be the same thing all right
Shane Dawson so to actual Shane Dawson
now you know I spent so much time trying
to understand all this last night and
it's just so thick the dramas so thick
the tea is like a thick brew you know
they call the thickest tea like English
English black English coffee what do
they call that that thick [ __ ] who's
talking about Earl Grey Earl Grey it's
not really great described it's thick
then sometimes I drink Earl Grey tea and
it's like greasy I'm like what is this
[ __ ] so this is Earl get gray drama so
I'm gonna try to skip it through as much
as possible I'm gonna paraphrase as much
as I can so last year oh my god how do I
even do this James Charles huge beauty
guru taxi made a video calling him a
sexual predator he got cancelled but
then he came with receipts and
uncancelled himself now one year later
people it's rumored that Shane Dawson
and Jeffrey star were behind manipulated
tatty into making her James Charles
video how's that okay thank you so so
basically Shane is being cancelled
Jeffrey's being canceled tattoos thrown
James Shane under the bus Shane makes an
apology video for doing blackface but
the problem here Shane's channel all
three of his channels have been totally
demonetized by YouTube and I'm I would
have never expected to see that I've
only ever seen that once before with
Logan Paul who literally filmed the
corpse and put it on his channel yes
yeah yeah yeah and Shane maybe they see
yeah he will they said
his suspension is indefinite but not
permanent I think what they did with
Logan pause they said I think they just
banned him for a month and said you have
to delete the offending content yada
yada yada I think that's what the I
think Shane will get it he'll get it
back in like a month but his reputation
is being creamed by by all this and so
honestly dude the videos are so dull I'm
not even gonna subject you like they're
all 40 minutes long the one thing I say
about the beauty drama is that these
people need to learn how to edit they
need to learn how to wrap it up
because like tatty goes on Shaunie is
the worst of Patty oh god I can't wait
we have to we have to post some
highlights so anyway the big thing is
that Shane has this weird history of
sexualizing kids and I think that's what
got the suspension for sure yeah and
especially the Smith family yes Will
Smith his family his wife and son came
down with some slam dunk tweets with
millions of likes yeah
because in a video back in the day Shane
Dawson is jokingly jerking off to a
picture of willow who's at the time was
like 11 bro I don't know how do you I
don't know what do you do about that
when the family themselves are so
offended and upset and their tweets have
millions of like yeah YouTube's like oh
[ __ ] here we go they felt they felt the
the current rising now the weird thing
with Shane is that he's been around for
so long thing I personally also don't
know what he was known for years ago
yeah cuz he's had like all these
different phases of rebranding and
trying different things with his channel
so I'm really not familiar with his past
and then all these things that are
surfacing are definitely problematic
clips
they're super old super all the same
yeah I mean it's a ton of blackface yeah
and he had this like racist character
yeah so in this video on the screen
taking accountability he pretty much is
just saying you know I used to do black
placement [ __ ] up and I regret it and
I hate myself but he doesn't address the
real problems here which is to sexualize
them of minors which is uh something
we'll get into but first I do just have
to absolutely have to look at this Totti
video so this was already happening to
him right and then Tati decided yeah
talk to you was oh yeah Tati kind of
just she's like Shane is having a really
bad time she's like my sister and now
all the sudden her and James Charles are
best friends I don't I to her look again
like I said at the beginning of the
podcast you know these are all real
people so I'm not going to say anything
to mean about the beautiful perfect I
can tell you that just looking at it all
from the side I'm getting so much
anxiety oh my god and it makes me feel
bad it's just like it's so on it's all
too much for any person in this world
like they're all just people and they're
dealing with so much drama like each of
these videos has tens of millions of
views and like a day I don't know it's
crazy that this one has 14 million
almost the amount of people that are
talking about them and accusing each
other of stuff it's I told Ella once
because when you get caught up in the
drama it's it's so bad it feels so bad I
was like it feels like somebody died
like and then like for the past few
years we've just been in so much [ __ ] or
like so many people making videos passes
up and at time like I feel like I've
gotten much better at handling it over
the years but you know I wasn't always
great I take that just you know I don't
know if it's accepting criticism or just
you know accepting the fact that there's
just gonna be people out there that
don't like you or
I don't know what it is but it's so
painful at times it's so it's just hurt
so bad I was like it feels like every
month somebody died like this amount of
stress and pressure it's just it can't
be I'm telling you I'm like this can't
be this has to be so bad for my health
that I'm feeling all the time just in so
much pain emotional pain so you know
there's also a real effect of like
trauma from it because it those moments
when like you get exposed or there's
like a bad video about it and you see it
it's like PST yeah there's real piteous
day from this stuff people people laugh
but I'm talking it the emotional pain
you feel is unparalleled yeah I've never
felt pain like that emotional pain like
that so I only liken it to losing a
loved one cuz I don't know anything I've
never lost a loved one there Wars I feel
like the really worst thing about it is
that it's boats super serious and really
petty like always right that's what's
that is right like if you meet anyone in
the real world outside of YouTube and
they're like what's going on with you
you have to be like oh nothing just some
drama people online so they did theirs
you're wrong and I don't see it that way
that's so true oh that's so frustrating
about it because like if you think of
back to like the whole Ethan exposed
thing it felt it was so much emotional
pain but it all just boiled down to like
he's he's cringing he had a bad
interview with bill burr or he's a
hypocrite I mean to shoot ice he was
mean to shoenice or whatever it's like
well okay you know imagine explaining
she rapes on that it says if you like
should be in a prison right now for life
ya know I mean this is a really good
conversation to have and so I think it's
important to bear in mind that I'm sure
these guys are all dealing with that
what we just described
Shane is having I can only met that let
me so tap but the thing is Kathy did not
need to get involved no she really just
kind of stepped into the crossfire here
i watch the video there was no point to
it my favorite part I'm not gonna watch
whole thing because of course it's like
a thousand years long here let's open
it's called breaking my slow minutes
first of all I just have to comment on
is she in a spa I mean where is she
filming this out of uh how does I have
to assume what is that she's got like
she's got like scented sticks
decorational object she's got a very
yeah sticks y'all she definitely pulls
they're like very like she looks really
good in her exposed videos where usually
people will be like no makeup they're
like I'm how bad she's mascot burp that
I said that part of me could you hear me
burping cuz it was like what the hell no
no Oh interesting
it felt very vulgar jenna Marbles in her
video was like no makeup I loved Jenna
she's such a she is a great person for
Todd hey it's like this is my appearance
Oh everything so perfectly but she's
wearing a piece shirt she got scented
sticks in the back I can't get over the
scented sticks her makeup is like
insanely on point right the first ten
seconds of this video is just a
masterclass in like it's just every
little detail about it I love it you
ready yeah
it's been a long time coming for me how
do you bust out in tears already after
hitting record I mean like can you
really a cute it's like so just imagine
the setting she's sitting there
comfortably perfectly posed so she had
to have come and hit the record and then
framed up perfectly and then she starts
and she's crying immediately as she goes
I mean that's pretty incredible it's
been a long time coming for me to share
with you some very very important things
and I am gonna be reading from what is
approved by my legal team so I am one
I love when lawyers talk about legal
[ __ ] by the way so I necessary come on
she makes some really funny legal claims
that cracking up yeah
dude she's got scented sticks bro
getting into what I need it's a mom it's
just awesome it's like I don't know why
to share with you I won't be deviating
and okay so anyway she said I'm not
gonna walk again this forty minutes of
her just crying crying and saying that
Shane and Jeff restart manipulated her
and to making the video but I'm saying
my whole response to that is like tatty
you are have your own agency as a human
being I find it very strange that you
would go out and make this statement
yeah but even if they did just take
they're just you gotta take the L you
made the video thank you you at the end
decided to make the video right no one
forced you to make the video even if
they were elect a T this is a huge
opportunity this kid deserves it you
have to like ultimately endured that
amount of peer pressure which I doubt
there was that amount of peer pressure
but I don't know I really don't but I
really doubt is that it's still you're
you're not you're not a teenager in high
school you're like a grown-ass woman
with scented sticks I mean the scented
sticks say a lot of things you guys
aren't appreciating it anyway there are
some points I want to highlight at the
end when she gets all legal is my
favorite [ __ ] she goes let's see she
thinks there's a massive conspiracy
this shit's this [ __ ] gets off the lot I
feel like she's actually a little bit
delusional at this point she starts to
go on about how there's a huge
conspiracy against her to sell beauty
products few months a few people have
bravely come forward with more
information and the pieces of what we
believe actually happened are coming
together make no mistake flip the page
this is far from over
I've been terrified for a very long time
so much so that I had to relocate again
two months ago and I have taken serious
security precautions to ensure my safety
on the advice I want I won't say
anything I know that feeling well
apparently tatsi does also it's let's
not it's unfortunately unrelated to
Shane don't it's like I don't know well
right because she made the video right
right right right right not sure with
all of you right now the evidence that
we have accumulated of the events that
have occurred however there will soon
come a day where we will be able to
present this evidence and you will be
able to see they reckon is believed that
Geoffrey and Shane are responsible for
so much of the damage that has been
caused so he has a receipts that she's
taken to court you can tell that she has
talked to lawyers also because she keeps
her she tries to explain the damages
which is such a lawyer thing right there
like when you try to bring a lawsuit to
it there lately well were there damages
and she tries to presenting like that I
had to relocate it's been a year oh
you're try so it's been a year of mental
so smart that's exactly what she's doing
she's trying to prove damages yeah
because when you sue someone for
defamation the hardest well first of all
it's extremely difficult to prove
defamation in California not just that
formation but then you have damage doing
but yeah well what the [ __ ] else could
she sue them for manipulating her to
make that's not get sue for that no like
what could you pop I don't this whole
thing is laughable like the of bringing
a lawsuit to someone for manipulating it
to making a video tell you this it's not
my opinion that Jeffery and Shane were
both bitterly jealous of James Charles's
success you were to Jeffery resented
that so much of his business was
centered around his biggest rival and
Shane did not like that James Charles
wanted to make a documentary
neither of them were happy with standing
in his shadow on YouTube any were bad my
lord I believe James Charles was gaining
more followers and receiving more view
after point out that time the whole
video she says James Charles maybe a
million times and she never once says
just James I find that incredibly
interesting what do you make of that
she'll say Shane not Shane Dawson or
Geoffrey is it she's trying to give him
respect is she trying to imply
familiarity is she that would do the
opposite do you would say James I should
say is she inadvertently implying that
she doesn't really know him well I don't
know and it's also my opinion that
Geoffrey and Shane needed
James marginalized and out of the way
for their November launch of the
conspiracy palette Wow pretty
that's so conspiratorial
out of the way why what does he have to
do with the silver there Cosmetics like
this [ __ ] is totally off the rails by
the time it came out James was already
uncannily
you know what I mean and their sales
were do insane like he's a huge
personality with a huge following
already I don't think they would even
think like that oh we need him out of
the way this is the culture that that I
think is the problem is that people
think of these youtubers it's like
supervillains they go yeah they go James
or sorry Shane and Geoffrey are plotting
to take down James so they can launch
their palette it doesn't make any sense
anyway talk to you the legend flip that
I've also recently been informed that
Geoffrey is allegedly a co-owner of
Murphy before the scandal unheard I had
also been told that James Charles was
about to develop an entire cosmetics
line with the owners of Murphy this
entire situation opens up a Pandora's
box of speculation uh uh but I'm just
not sure anyone counted on this drama
spreading like wildfire it's my opinion
that everyone involved got scared
and their plan changed multiple times as
I refused to play along or engage with
the drama over the next several months a
year later it is now my opinion that
James Charles was not their only
intended target I believe that there are
many different people who have unclean
hands in all of this and there was a
coordinated beauty [ __ ] drama do you
understand what beauty drama is it's a
no you just made basically an expose
video then you regretted it - this is
new boy yeah bro
everybody's got blood on their hands or
should I say foundation on their hands
you know me quiet and push me out of the
way for other business reasons I do not
think it's a coincidence that more if he
is about to launch their own brand of
hair skin nail gummy vitamins but I do
think it was just Shane and Jeffrey this
didn't benefit from my being silent so
bitter that other people are making
money this was just too big
cuz she also wants us to she also
launched her own both [ __ ] vitamin
line that Shane helped her do well that
was the was the original issue remember
that that that's why she got mad at
James Charles cuz he promoted a rival
vita' jealous she was doing just because
he promoted an Instagram story some
gummy that was a rival and she had a
meltdown right I forgot that was the
whole genesis yes and now here she is
still talking about the same [ __ ] you
got scented sticks what more do you want
now in life no wrinkle in this thing is
really interesting what do you guys
think about the fact that in this video
she says that she made this video with
the consent and in coordination with
James I okay
haven't like commented at all it's just
nice Twitter like an hour ago when I
will speculate and please bear in mind
that this is pure speculation I don't
know but what I think happened is that
she and James and I'm only saying this
because this should happen to me in the
Internet
this what I think happened okay I think
he like keemstar does this [ __ ] all the
time he's done it to mean he's done to
other people he goes you have what you
think is just a normal conversation with
somebody and then without asking for
permission you take everything they said
and then use it in your argument without
without consent you'll have a casual
conversation in the DMS and then they
make a video and they totally quote what
you said yeah it's like but it's like
dude if I knew you for not a lot of
people but it's kind of like a people do
or small you can't you can't if you're
asking me for public statement I'm gonna
think more about it and prepare
something more thoughtful
you can't just be having a conversation
class whole conversation mate I then
like take that as let Goss gospel well
she at some point in this video goes so
far as to say that uh James wishes that
he could be here next to me for this
video I think it's bull he wouldn't be
there yeah if he wish so bad he would be
but he would be able to debunk this all
very easily
nobody he's probably so tired of this no
it was so hard on him probably the most
you know the most difficult it was on
him the best thing I needed was finally
out of it yeah like it makes total sense
that he would say nothing yes the best
thing he could do is just shut up she's
not she's not slamming him she's not
doing anything she's just trying to you
know curry favor with his fans again
this is speculation so yeah I don't know
if the [ __ ] I'm talking about and they
could have and everything she's saying
could be right you know what to your
point I just looked because we had
looked earlier jeffree star Shane and
Tati are all like bleeding subscribers
like crazy I just looked at James
Charles he's fine yeah James is killing
it yeah so he's the only one coming hi
sisters what do you think these scented
sticks I think they're vanilla scented
she seems like a virtue you think it's
patchouli you think vanilla is too basic
for her yeah yeah you might
but vanilla chili it's probably too
basically for if I know it's the you
know it's a you know it's uh it's a
Tibetan Tibetan Tibetan see the Tibetan
Gwyneth Paltrow's cave vagina
alright and I have every intention of
getting to the truth in early May when
Jeffrey went on a podcast and denied
responsibility for his involvement and
placed blame on me it was both cowardly
I made the video I mean hello weak when
Shane issued his statements about his
involvement in all of this I also
perceived them as cowardly open
defamatory the family as for everyone
else involved that did anything
underhanded or defamatory over the last
year I am still well within the statute
of limitations for bringing a civil
action to seek recovery for my damages
should I proceed with this course of
actions my attorneys went into posing
all witnesses who have information about
the truth of what happened here so for
everyone else whose hands are dirty they
have not yet come forward be careful of
your allegiance you don't want to be on
the wrong side of the truth do it the
wrong side what is this like world war
two you almost went full Papa their
reckoning is coming she did kind of say
that this [ __ ] went so over the thoughts
unable to provide you with receipt so
that was that kind of this forty minute
video that was like the that was really
the heart of it and my favorite part so
she's suing and opposing everybody I
hope she doesn't oppose me
I mean hey I don't know nothing about
nothing I don't know nothing about any
gummy vitamins for your hair then Shane
oh my favorite is Shane so sheep so
Shane is already getting [ __ ] on by
buddy and he's already had his channels
demonetised I don't know why I'm doing
this out of order but I just love tot
tease video I'm gonna go back and
explain to that but Shane reacts to her
video when it comes out he for some
reason his immediate reaction is a go on
Instagram live because he's just
freaking out and respond to her video so
here this is I'm live because I can't
even process I need a drink of water
I [ __ ] can't processes this is insane
I don't know why but a batch in the pan
the pain is real I just want to
emphasize that I feel bad yeah this is
insane this is insane
this woman is [ __ ] oh my god oh my
god I'm gonna wait till as many people
get in here as possible because like
it's crazy that these people aren't
flicking so much pain on each other yeah
god it's so ruthless out there man but
it's [ __ ] up because it is when you're
on the sidelines it's so it's just so
sinfully entertaining yeah yeah it's a
problem it's that it's that show it in
Freud and mm-hmm I didn't said that [ __ ]
them sure shut shut
sure site in Freudian schadenfreude in
I'm not even a German word for getting
pleasure from other peoples yes
schadenfreude in yeah something like
that yeah but I also feel bad I really
do
because she is a [ __ ] up I can't I
can't we were trying to guess about what
he was gonna say I think you'll be
worried I think he was gonna say liar
this is insane this person could not be
because everything about her so like
yeah and then cubits here yeah you know
I mean and think you got the Quentin
vagina scented sticks in the background
perfectly played that is not I love the
suggestive video my god what's next
he's so anyway he just bails at this
point and I think he was just he was
just full like wow it's like wow could
it get worse and then all the sudden
Tati enters in the battlefield
sticks another shiven ashamed of island
his that as a husband or a boyfriend
I think fiance's okay so he comes out he
goes this is [ __ ] hot and I'm losing
my mind
32 seconds there that was they erased it
yeah his fiance goes in he says not
today [ __ ] do not tray me right
now try hope you enjoyed those sold-out
vitamins that you made millions and
minutes from Shane support you to face
Flyer catotti Westbrook a master class
and what did the [ __ ] is this I was
wondering what is Obi
eh is it an emoji it must have been a
didn't show right a masterclass in
manipulation the only the only was to
save her reputation was decide with the
person she tried to ruin make no mistake
this 40 year old woman she chose to post
a video on her own accord
she riled up Shane before doing so to
have one of the biggest creators backing
her and the chance this all backfired
Shane very well would have posted a
video explain exposing James had he felt
so inclined no receipts because she
didn't want to expose the countless
times she told Shane that she was a big
girl doing this only for herself I'm
inclined to believe those that this
makes a lot of sense to me well it's
just logical right it's like yeah yeah
Shane is the kind of guy that if he had
something to say he would say it himself
from what I've seen online well it
doesn't really make sense to me that he
would look regardless of whatever you
think of Shane ultimately she is a she's
a 40 years old you cannot blame other
people for yeah actions that you take
I mean you just can't anyway juice the
drama is just so-so
so anyway let's go pull it back here so
why did Shane get dropped from YouTube
now this is when we get pretty weird
okay first of all shout out to this
channel without a crystal ball who who
really love his love baby public enemy
number one Shane Dawson let's she did
the grill egg work on this she got every
receipt on the earth on Shane Dawson so
let's start these were the ones that I
hand-picked to be what I thought were
the most damaging against Shane so here
we go let's go down the rabbit hole
Shane Dawson justifies pedophile
molesting children because he felt well
here I'll let it speak for itself
it's obviously extremely old the clip I
don't know what years gone from the
haircut yeah man it's crazy that
everyone like thought that haircut was
cool like a Smosh had it it's just it
looks so corny now but I wonder what's
that version of today
right like you thought was
five-years-old like that was his thing I
saw much TV talking about it all the
time oh he's guilty he's 5 so basically
she's five years old mentally right but
sexually so it's like if there's a weird
like link missing where it's like I'm
five years old but I am 40 but I find
other five-year-olds sexually attractive
because I'm 5 years old too so
interested so it kind of makes sense to
me even though it's horrible and I don't
think molesting children is good it kind
of makes sense to me why he actually
molest children and that's kind of so
this is something he said a lot and
first of all it's just weird to go to
your way to justify pedophilia but his
analogy is way off because
five-year-olds don't want to have sex
he says he's mentally five years old so
of course wants to [ __ ] kids but
five-year-olds aren't sexual that's the
whole point
they can't consent to sex so I don't
know but but okay so this alone is not
really anything it's a pattern of that
emerges I find it strange that he can
continue to hold this opinion because
you see it throughout the years that he
keeps saying the same thing like this
theory he has about about trying to just
fight and I think really where it comes
from and I'm not a psychologist so I am
not qualified to really analyze this but
he mentions that he was molested himself
and I feel like he probably has a like
got some hey he's got issues with some
on the resolve which like if yeah I mean
yeah there's not at all any evidence
that he's actually done anything to know
you know to victimize kids I mean like
let's anybody think that's what I'm
saying there's no evidence that
and I'm there's no way I would I'm
accusing him of that I think he's got
you know he says he was molested and he
obviously has some weird he has some
sexual hang-ups from that which is only
natural you know it's so damn it's one
of the most damaging the in fact it's a
problematic combination with him because
he also was trying this like really edgy
humor a lot and at that time I think
also edgy humor on the internet was very
like gross like not like today's it
sounds to me like he's trying to
rationalize what happened to him in a
weird way to make it seem like more okay
in his mind like you you explain things
in your mind to make it okay they call
it rationalizing and it seems to me he's
probably rationalized something that
happened to him as a kid because you
know when you get assaulted as a child
you always blame yourself and you carry
a lot of blame and guilt and so I think
you know I think there's probably a lot
going on with him how he thinks about it
in his mind and how then how he sees it
you know but he's not an abuser I mean
there's no evidence of that but then
here we go but there is there's really a
problem with his behavior when you see
this it's like the dude needs to resolve
this issue and not keep doing like here
he is with his 12 year old cousin no
friend so we want to talk to you we want
to explain what sex is we take it real
quick or smell the smoke so this makes
it really creeps okay well why do keep
and then we'll use you totally
inappropriate so just pretend like
that's you know I mean that works
and then I can't believe I'm endorsing
you've turned me into so so Lucy does
that make sense
but Lucy listen you should be in love
and you should preferably be married and
hopefully not have any kids okay and you
should definitely be over the age of
like 20 or 25 and you should put a ring
and you should put a ring on it
no I'm kidding no do you don't know what
that is you shouldn't know what that is
now are you on your period right now I'm
trying to get answers how are you are
you know you're not on your period you
believe no no listen you have a
boyfriend right yes now what did I tell
you when he says can I put it in you say
no good high five girlfriend oh now wait
he know what he says what about you say
just your mom no you say I bite so I
think in their mind they they're just
being told everybody I think they're
just being like edgy and fannia like a
she doesn't know we're talking about but
but I think it's in a problem I'm trying
I'm trying I'm trying to get I'm trying
to explain it but it's hard well I think
like you said before it's it's about the
it's the volume and it's the pattern
it's all of these every one of these
individually it's like alright that's a
little cringy but you could maybe
explain it away but I mean we compiled a
list right I'm not done yeah there's
like 40 of these billion but I
hand-picked there's probably like 50 I
had there was not so I picked out like
the ones that I thought were the most
compelling dude there was like a
bajillion of these so let's see and okay
so when Justin Bieber was like a tiny
kid he was 16 years old the way you ever
decided to be like porn star what would
his porn star name be here are some of
my personal favorites just in Beaver
just in queefer just
in my mouth and thrusting beaver and
there was even some ideas for porn movie
titles and I can't decide which one is
my favorite except at one time or one
less lonely [ __ ] Rose what do you
think Justin which one do you like look
how young here you know what Justin how
about we make both what do you think
yeah perfect JB I'll be over soon so
last meeting that should that part with
the camera at the end really did me
wrong to be honest
inappropriate sigh so Zach stop jack
that's a 16 year old boy that wasn't me
Vin Diesel's back here man so you know
do you think we could ever get vin
diesel on the show oh my god I love to
have Vin Diesel next Fast & Furious I
just hit him up like what's up Batman
talk to me baby voice is such how do you
say it's got such tannin is that the
right word or tamped amber Ben Burtt
it's got amber like [ __ ] four days
amber hit me with that again like that
it sounds like he sounds like he smokes
so it's like this oh he does smoke I've
seen pictures of him smoke it so he's
got the smokers like no it's more than
that death rattle he's got so much
Tambor you could build a house out of it
I'm out here on the fly Dan all right
Shane let's not lose focus here this
child first of all I'm just gonna say
that this video is edited to make it
gets creepy as possible with terrifying
ambient sounds in the background so bear
that in mind don't be try not to be
manipulated by it
not by us no no no no not is this child
is probably six years old
and I was taking a picture of something
and the kid turns to me and goes oh are
you instagramming and first of all how
does a five-year-old six year old know
what Instagram is just terrifying
second of all I was embarrassed because
yes I was and it was a picture of my
salad and the six-year-old girl goes oh
how many followers do you have I have a
hundred and twenty five thousand no her
take was almost as big as mine really
and I said okay little big dick why do
you have so many followers and she goes
oh I'm a cheerleader and I'm like oh
really and she shows me her instagrams
which are like first of all I don't know
if I'm allowed to say this but she's
like a sexy she's like you sexy do not
say this and do like I don't want to
talk about it like you will get arrested
like he kind of education just took
vacation for pedophilia and it's so
disturbing and like I just pretend that
he doesn't let me explain let me explain
here's my justification for pedophilia
thank you you can tell she's like
serious she's trying to make like he
thinks he's just doing like funny
material doing a bit yeah but I think
that's where the he has no like limit
when it comes to this topics I think
that's where the trauma from his
childhood probably comes in and that's
I'm speaking of course from my place of
absolutely no expertise yeah but where a
normal person would have that filter
that awareness he may not like it
doesn't know where to draw the line to
him it seems an orphan appropriate yes
[Music]
here's my thing people have foot
fetishes people have fetishes about you
know everything fine everybody do your
thing so why is it when somebody looks
at a googles like naked baby on Google
and jerks off to it they can get
arrested I heard this one that it's the
worst analogy okay let me let me answer
you Shane first of all if there's
pictures of naked children that means
that they're the victim of a crime okay
pictures of feet don't doesn't
necessarily mean that there's there's a
victim if there's naked pictures of a
babies and or god forbid actually being
committed sex acts on your there is a
victim to this crime first of all and
second of all pedophilia isn't just a
fetish it's a it's a it's a it's about
control and power and victimizing
somebody so from what I understand it's
not like do you agree with what I'm
saying you're just looking disgusted but
my correct
I wonder if you're doing justice
explaining it well enough I don't know I
just the first time I'm hearing it you
know I think I like processing what I
just heard no you can't compare it to a
foot fetish that's insane yeah
that's insane no because the child is a
victim I mean that's really it's not
like a victimless crime you like will
just poop in my mouth that's weird it's
weird but nobody gets hurt that's not
true with pedophilia there's always a
victim even if it's just pictures online
and you say I'm just I'm just looking at
the pictures I'm not doing it you are
supporting a system in which by the very
nature of it existing has to have
victims mm-hmm and it's one of the
really one of the worst crimes you can
commit to a person mm-hmm so it's just
writing it off as a fetish is actually
it's like wait dude actually you know
what this is is really like um I feel
like he's a [ __ ] pedophile apologist
it's like super weird I feel like this
is how pedophiles justify it to
themselves so they can live with
themselves they go just a fetish
I don't know though but it's a very
weird statement understand because
turkey off too baby something the
thought I'm just reading that it's just
crazy yeah
oh no this bark
hold on I actually went to Google and
I'm like oh god I want to see it I know
but I just wanted to see like okay let
me just pretend let me pretend like I'm
a pedophile first I'll pretend I don't
want to pretend that so I typed in naked
baby first of all so I look at this
little girl's pictures and she had
makeup on she had her tongue out she was
doing like the peace sign she was doing
the backflip she like honey boo boo see
that no she was like the skinny little
sexy six dude that [ __ ] is so wild this
is the worst one that I just did not
hear before for some reason I have a
stumble I feel like there's there is it
wasn't there weird movement to like
normalize pedophilia on the internet Dan
where they had like yeah let's go
fortune no no there was like a bunch of
Twitter accounts and they had like a
emoji in their name or in their title uh
and they they know and they there's like
people that try to normalize pedophilia
and I think they maybe there's there's
the NAMBLA thing what is NAMBLA NAMBLA
is like a national association of man
man boy loves yeah that's I mean it's
what you're saying yeah I mean it's a
pedophilia and pedis tree advocacy okay
so maybe a NAMBLA I'm thinking up and I
think what Shane's just described as one
of their kind of rationalizations of
being like hey pedophilia is just
another sexual fetish no it's a sickness
yeah it's a mental illness right that's
right so that one's pretty weird
and then he so then he goes on to
explain that one cuz he got [ __ ] for
that and this let's see this he explains
in 2018 which is actually kind of recent
he says no
that videos all jokes taken out of
context and as all the punchlines
removed it is also is illegal to claim
someone is a someone who's a pedophile
and use six year-old jokes as proof
again I love delete everyone trying to
get legal it I do not believe that that
is illegal
no of course it's not also we're talking
about civil um not crit there's not a
criminal yeah weird takes yeah I cannot
really take this as an explanation
there's no conflict well we just heard
ya em was the same back here that I
guess Shane did at some point release
what we just heard unedited and he he in
that clip says that he's just joking
actually makes me better well of course
he would say that I mean my mouth Dan
you I'm not actually eating it's just an
outwit it's a mint I wish a damn it
sorry can you say again will you bring
in some areas bringing out meds now and
what did you say I said that Shane he
said I'm just kidding he just said I'm
just kidding in that clip yeah in that
clip in in a longer unedited clip
without a didgeridoo but I feel like
there has to be a limit that's crossing
a line of just kidding doesn't doesn't
make it so anyway yada yada yada there's
more I mean this is the short stack
right there was like a Quebec Jeep could
you cook a julienne do we yes Dan
[Applause]
don't even know when a pubic hair is
[Applause]
what's your name random fan
four-year-old sister already getting
sexual yeah yeah oh this one I got a
show I know you guys are over it but
this one's so weird because it features
[ __ ] Rafi fine the fine brother
I hope is just here no it's which I
figured it out we it's moving I was
watching this tonight all right I got a
tongue it was a really good it was a
really good spot though no because I was
like I was like wow this video is so
disturbing what in the [ __ ] is this and
then for a moment it swings over to the
puppet master and I was like holy [ __ ]
that's that's a fine brother that's Rafi
fine and then Dan looked it up and we
100% confirmed
hey it's milli bye Rafi fine you'll see
the ice it's a hundred percent confirmed
to touch yourself in the nether regions
[Music]
why don't you why don't you touch
yourself a little bit you see Rafi fine
right it's just it just blew my mind
that he was oh that was quite a twist
nobody is mentioning that Rafi fine is
doing some weird pedophile puppet
doesn't that I was like oh my god later
in the same clip you see the other fine
brother right so actually I don't think
it's the other fine bro I look very
closely it doesn't look like him all
right
[Laughter]
like here you want to see it you want to
examine it to me I looked really cool I
mean it would make sense that it's in
but see it doesn't look like him does it
I don't think so
just to prove it so people don't know
I'm making [ __ ] up here here's the
puppet
hey it's Millie okay created by Rafi and
Benny fine and Shane Dawson owes a
collaboration weird Millie is an 8 year
old girl who may seem innocent but in
almost every single video she's in she
says inappropriate words make sexual any
windows and she doesn't understand his
meaning and says she is wet Oh from
sexual arousal 2010 what was going on
with when humor back then Internet in
that area is very fringe in retrospect
yeah really is okay so now we get to the
Smiths okay so we can we're done with
all that did this this is what I think
YouTube was like alright this is [ __ ]
crazy
so here yeah so anyway so then so I mean
okay that coming off the back of
everything we talked about is is you
know weird he just continues to do this
but then the Smith family comes out with
the heat Jada Smith the mom to Shane
Dawson I'm done with the excuses
I'm not sure what that means but you
know I think I understand after I saw
the amount of clips because she probably
saw it already she probably saw one or
two and she was like okay maybe it's a
joke and I don't get it maybe this maybe
that but when you see like the whole
totality of it maybe she was like I'm
done with the excuses and you know the
Smith family is well connected with
YouTube Will Smith could call Susan
Wojcicki
just just like me just like you yeah I'd
be like yo be like oh yeah I guess
rewind time ones shame Bob she goes
hello and he's like yeah yeah and she's
like oh hi Smith Will Smith so I think
the Smith family brought the hammer down
and then Jayden Smith you know the
famous
I mean poet name is a thinker
philosopher Shane Dawson I'm disgusted
by you sexualizing eleven-year-old girl
who happens to be my sister is the
furthest thing from funny and not okay
in the slightest bit 1.1 million likes
yeah hello who's this yeah oh hey well
Oh
Oh Shane did what oh that's not cool
yeah okay I'm gonna get right on that
will smile wait hold on hold on
he did what yeah that is totally
unacceptable okay we're talking about
serious stuff here yeah but you know
there's always time for some good Will
Smith uh-huh so anyway it all comes full
circle and I go back to something that
happened recently and we all speculated
about this and I think I was on one of
the only ones who said you know what I
think he did it
and what am I talking about let me play
this for you
get arrested for this I don't know
nothing about it
mmm I don't think so okay go ahead enjoy
a little chicken legs like you know
spread open all right other I was like
if I just like humph but like honors
tummy like that's not weird like I never
and then I humped it I hunted I haven't
kept going no you sexual experience no I
said from the very first moment I think
he caught it came on that cat because it
was way too specific and way too
detailed and he said he was kidding and
I was like ah he's just kidding that
shame I think that cat got come Don I
was one of the greatest memes wasn't it
when he wrote his tweet tweet I did not
cut first of all I did not come on my
cat and everyone's like whoa yeah oh
yeah yeah I think he [ __ ] oh no he
didn't [ __ ] his cat well he rubbed his
dick on his cat I guess but like in the
context of everything we've just seen
raise your hand who thinks Shane came on
as cat well know wouldn't he he said he
humped the cat he's not [ __ ] the cat
well tip what he didn't penetrate yeah
yeah but would that still be [ __ ] if
you're I mean it depends are you did he
come on the cat came on the cat who came
on the cat I'm not going on the record
no no I think he [ __ ] okay yeah you're
right is we shouldn't but I mean I think
that coming on the cat is at least
okay let's don't trivialize any of this
is all very serious so uh that's pretty
much it if you've come to that's the
tsys and that's the tea yes it's pretty
crazy I everybody loses in this story
yes fortunately oh there was one thing I
wanted to show is that the crystal ball
lady right who was the keeper the
gatekeeper of all this drama and I do
want to be is the not having a crystal
ball the lady her channel name is oh
she's got a great intro - do you wanna
watch yeah I do
so it's at 3:30 so I can know where I
was doing this bro [ __ ] c/e
oh I laugh I thought it was like yeah
topical funny yeah so anyway that's her
intro love it god bless
so back this is super interesting she
just made this video in response to
Tottie's video and she said back in the
day she wrote a video about the drama
and involving tatty and then tact he had
her lawyers contact her to remove [ __ ]
I'm like she just wrote an article about
it yeah let her explain but what I
really want to point out is that she was
a pillow in the back that says love is
love it's the best which if you think
about it man it means absolutely nothing
at all and it's so funny I just find it
so funny love is love love is love baby
what else could it be hmm
what else could love be but love it's
all love love is love
hmm is T love no love is love he is t he
can't make money on YouTube Sony hope
his videos it's yes right here so
there's a sound machine and so you know
a lot of people were like why is taki
speaking out now whatever I'm not here
to say like I don't like taki I'm really
no 20 by the way a 20 minute video that
I think I can boil down to 30 seconds
when she finally gets to the point love
is love I don't like feel any sort of
like I hate you or motional just do I
like some of her behavior okay here we
go last year I wrote a piece and and
after doing that what happened love is
like the article and I completely
changed the way that it wasn't the
article was put together and I took out
any of the things
that was 30 seconds of a 20-minute video
but I just really love love is love I
love love is love I believe that was too
reliant Shakespeare wrote that line
originally love is love actually now we
move on to a very it's like such a weak
man talked about dog we're talking about
Shane now we got to move on to crystally
a friend of the show and all of these
guys were on the show everybody we've
ever been a ghost I'm the commonality
yep
you did this ah you know what it really
sucks is that I really like all these
guys on a personal level doc is like so
well first of all I'm not accusing
anything of doc let me step back I'm not
saying anything wrong I don't know what
he did I
doc is an awesome dude though he was
like super entertaining super funny such
a great cast
Shane is a don't know them on a personal
level of them for my you're right from
my perception of having them wise I
guess having ran into them yeah but well
Chris D'Elia I actually do know more on
a personal level than these other people
for example even then it's not like we
hung out we excited this no but he like
when we when Theodore was born he sent
us a gift and I thought I was like oh my
god that's so thoughtful mm-hmm like he
was one of the few people that sent us a
gift and like for him to have followed
that and it was a really nice gift it
was like a really cool toys and blanket
was a really beautiful bat I was like I
was honestly tough I was like wow that's
so thoughtful of him to send that yeah
we texted a couple of times about like
Metamucil we were laughing because I was
like dude Metta me it's a safe Braille
chant as a game changer and we were
laughing about Metamucil and stuff so I
would you know I liked him a lot
as they do it I thought he was like you
know on his act he's kind of crass and
he's very like I'll just say and do what
I want and [ __ ] you but I was like wow
you know on a personal level my dealings
with the person I was like he's such a
sweet tender caring guy
so when these accusations about Chris
came out I was I should honestly my
first reaction was just like dude like
why why why did you have like why man
why would you risk anything to just
blurt with these girls on Instagram and
[ __ ] snapchats like why would you do
why would you put yourself at risk just
like [ __ ] why man why are you doing
this that's a sickness
that's what's a sex addiction it must be
some kind of thing because she Chris
always makes a big deal about how he
doesn't do drug or I don't know if he
makes a big deal but like it's very
remarkable Ike he's like I've never I he
always he says I have never tried any
drug I've never said alcoholic ever
smoked a single puff of weed and it's
remarkable that why would so it's almost
like his addiction is sex is what it
seems like which is I mean this the
[ __ ] up thing about a sex addiction is
that again there's there's a fact it by
definition includes other people who are
probably you know are gonna be deeply
affected by what you do smoking weed and
alcohol maybe it can affect your family
as a byproduct but ultimately it's
something you're doing to yourself you
don't need other people's consent I'm
not saying he raped anyone but like
there's a power dynamic and I think I
think it's just you know I really hate
to see and I've seen it a lot when these
celebrities with power and influence
indiscriminately use that to just [ __ ]
girls and they like and try to control
and manipulate and it's just like dude
why you can funk you can get a normal
girl you can get a girl because like
he's 30 I think or forty ways he's forty
think he's not for anything he was 35
and the time of some of those stories
and so all like the vast majority the
girls are like right on the cusp of 18
like super young ass attitude
how about just [ __ ] a 25 year old if you
want a younger girl you know or just
like fine like a normal girl look here's
the thing about 18 year olds and girls
around that age is that like they're on
the most part I don't want to
discriminate against younger people but
the maturity level against someone who's
like 2530 is just so vast
oh yeah and when you read their stories
they say the only reason I responded is
because I told my friends this guy
messaged me and he's verified and all
this stuff and the friends were like
always famous you gotta respond yeah
because when you're 18 it's mesmerizing
it's like yeah adjectives in general
there's a lot of gravity towards being a
celebrity right like it's like this
mythical magical thing and you can
really influence people with that but
it's like but when you're talking about
I you know thinking back to myself as a
teen I know that weed legally consider
eighteen year olds adults but like I was
very much still a child at that age yeah
you know I was far from adult at 18 he
was an adult but he was like the problem
solook was the one that should have
known better so I was very disappointed
and you know I just like dude why why
did you why everything going for him he
was on top of the world he was like he's
featured in this huge Netflix
blockbuster that was like a hundred
million dollar budget that like and it's
like dude he was on his way he had it
all but I just don't understand why why
would you risk all that just stuff [ __ ]
some young girls man anyway let's talk
about what actually happened there was
first of all I was like the enormity
there was like dozens of girls that came
out with similar stories
he said I'll start with his statement on
all this he said to TMZ I know I have
said and done things that might have
offended people during my career but I
have never knowingly pursued any
underage woman at any point Chris goes
on to say all of my relationships have
been both
legal and consensual and I have never
met or exchanged any inappropriate
photos with the people who have tweeted
about me he finishes by saying that
being said I really am truly sorry I was
a dumb guy who absolutely let myself get
caught up in my lifestyle that's my
fault I own it I've been reflecting on
this for some time now and I promise I
will continue to do better so I think in
the beginning it started with some
Twitter threads with those girls saying
girl got one here he reached out to me
Oh 18 you know it was the craziest thing
that made it even worse is that he
played a pedophile twice right and
separate shows first on workaholics the
second time and you dude that made it so
much worse and the the you one was far
worse because not only was it a
pedophile he was playing a comedian that
preyed on young girls he's basically
playing himself oh my god they said
let's see what does just send me a pet
she sends a she was six she claims to
she was 16 at the time of this
conversation and he was apparently you
know in 34 35 it was in 2014 sent a pic
she sends a panda and he says ha ha the
[ __ ] panda dick there very exotic
is that it I guess she's just saying he
was I mean yeah you don't want to ask a
six-year-old for big for pictures oh
here's another one imagine being 16
being groomed by stand-up comedian twice
your age and the only reason you never
met up and got physically molester was
because you had just gotten a boyfriend
your own age
she says he says hey I'm in your town
let's hang do you want to meet up
tonight yes can we make out yes sir so
like yeah there's no proof here exactly
of something illegal happening just from
this screenshot but the problem is that
you start to see the pattern of what he
was doing across all these different
stories and it you can definitely see
predatory behavior he a lot of times
would start talking to them on Instagram
and the switch to email or text or
whatever but on their Instagram day a
lot of them say he could clearly see my
age you know like if you're under speed
of a 16 year old yeah he so he says I I
didn't ever knowingly pursue anyone
underage and that might be true but you
knew that they were you knew for sure
that they were like right there I'd be a
little under maybe a little over but
even regardless of that it's like
I I don't know it's like to you let's
say this guy really likes sex it's the
only thing he cares about in the world
and he's like I'm famous I'm attractive
I just want to [ __ ] whoever wants to
[ __ ] me and so he's like I'm traveling
on all these towns I'm going everywhere
I'm going everywhere is that I just want
to [ __ ] people that want to [ __ ] me he's
gonna [ __ ] all the time and so he's
messaging everybody's like hey I wanna
[ __ ] on five on five yeah the problem is
that there is a common theme here that
shows they're too young
yeah he's targeting people that are too
young yeah at least for me that just
from observing what I'm saying
it's definitely behavior that I think
the problem is when you target someone
that's so young - is that like there's a
good chance that you because of your
celebrity status you'd be putting them
in a position they're not fully
comfortable with even though they are
consenting yeah that's why he's abusing
his power yeah cuz they'll be like
they'll come over like oh my god it's
Chris D'Elia and then it'd be like you
want to drink and then he'll start
acting inappropriately and then cheap
maybe she's like I don't want to say no
because it's Chris D'Elia and well I
came here and of course he's expecting
this of me and so they end up in the
situation that they're very
uncomfortable with and they go through
with it because of they're embarrassed
or they're ashamed or yada yadi awright
so like let's say it's not explicitly
rape but he's putting people in
situations that that they they are
probably not fully comfortable with yeah
and and they're so young they don't
really know how to behave how do ya it's
a good point because I feel like a lot
of people will misunderstand this
situations and they're like well if
someone didn't rape her then she consent
to who's there by choice what's the
problem
yeah it's great it's a career it's he's
the adult in the situation and he needs
to know better and to do better and not
abuse his power and the fact that
this this went on for a really long time
among a lot of girls and so and so he
kind of must like it can happen watching
you like Paul do it and then maybe like
man that was like maybe I crossed the
line
maybe I whatever whatever but here's
these are specific stories that came out
in the LA Times because there's just
tons of anonymous people not anonymous
but tons of claims and accusations very
similar to this one with Twitter and
some of them had to go in on him is
because they were actually getting a
[ __ ] on by his fence which is another
problem for victims to to come out with
your story is not that easy no I totally
agree it's horrifying because like you
already feel guilty in you already feel
ashamed but then so the most [ __ ] up
thing is that you feel guilty and
ashamed because you know that if you
don't say anything
then you'll enable other people to go
through what you did so it's almost like
it's not they don't want the attention
right you have to understand that they
are they can't live with the guilt of
knowing that they're allowing this to
happen to more people so that is like a
torturous I just got to be awful feeling
like you don't want to go out in the
spotlight you've been put in this
position by somebody else you don't you
have this damage from somebody else you
just want to move on and get on with
your life but at the same time you know
that that person is still doing that and
so you you have to you see yourself as
obligated to say something morally it's
just it's it's on all front and then you
know that is people call you a liar and
so it's just a horrible horrible
horrible it's not a good sort of
attention taste and nothing to gain from
it to victims like yeah it's horri mean
that's just there's just there's just a
pilot it's just the worst on all from
all sides it's awful for your family to
hear about what happened to you it's
awful for everyone and then on top of
that you have to deal with fans of that
person we're gonna come at you and call
your liar email you call you or call you
a liar yeah I mean dude I don't
I think the amount I think first of all
there are fake allegations and that [ __ ]
is so [ __ ] to actually go on record
and falsely accuse someone is as heinous
as doing the act itself mm-hmm
but I think there's not as many fake
accusations as a lot of people believe
there are not even close yeah I mean
there are them and that fact that they
exist is true oh yeah they are heinous
is true yeah but whenever someone comes
out with the story
your reaction shouldn't be immediately
like oh this is um fake allegations it's
okay to want to read more and get the
full picture but it's fair to be like
let's pump the brakes and let all the
information come out before I make any
judgment that's that's a yeah that's
probably the best approach but the
person's right to immediately attack
back is just a bad idea because if it is
true and it most likely is true it is
most likely you HOT you can't argue
really I mean I mean I can tell you from
my personal life I like maybe like 95%
of the females that I know have a story
that is real so it's crazy it's way more
than people realize way way way way more
yeah that's right it is crazy it is
crazy so well anyway those are all just
on Twitter but that LA Times did an
investigation and this is all
corroborated so this is like real
journalism I mean this is the LA Times
so these stories are are to me really
really kind of seal the deal here he
says one of those fans was Jackie Cohen
a UCLA student who first started talking
to Julia when he responded to a picture
of her on snapchat she said their their
conversation moved to text message he
wrote to her from the same number he
used to correspond with another person
Holtzman and
immediately sexual cowan shared screen
shots of their exchange with the times
hey hey he first said in June 2017 hey
what you up to she responded you want to
suck my [ __ ]
he replied wasting no time Jesus should
we not read this is it as part of the I
mean it's important I think it's
important the 19 year old told the the
19 year old told the 37 year old she
would give him oral sex telling him she
was looking for nothing but fun and
would be gone with no strings after the
potential account that sounds like a
perfectly fine experience right two
consenting adults but then this is when
it gets really weird right
he goes how badly do you want to hang
out with me Cohen said of the exchanges
I said pretty bad you're really cute
we get along we don't have to go out but
he kept wanting me to prove myself
before we could hang out after months of
on and off messaging Thalia wrote to her
out of the blue in August 2017 I want
you to suck my friend tonight
will you go do that for me soon
thereafter she said she began receiving
phones and video calls from an older man
who identified himself as Delia's best
friend he told me Chris just wants to
make sure you're real I want nothing I
promise Chris is making out to be more
than it is Cohen said of the
conversation he kept asking for my dress
so we can meet up and I could be
approved to meet Chris but I wouldn't
tell him where I lived I only told him I
lived in Encino later that night she
said she received angry messages from
Delia inquiring why she uh not met his
friend my brother my buddy quote my
buddy drove to you what the [ __ ] said a
screenshot text
Jimmy Cowan Jackie's brother told the
times he was sitting with her while the
exchange was happening and was creeped
out finding Delia was request
hilariously pathetic Chris never had my
consent to promise my body to anyone
added Jackie I don't deserve to be
treated that way I never disrespected
him what hasn't been
what hasn't been that widely report is
that Chris did release a lot of emails
with the girls that publicly accused him
showing that they left out crucial
messages regarding their age what is
that 10 that's his article from 625 yeah
he he since then and the story is kind
of gotten buried a little bit he he
most of the main people that accused him
on twitter he went ahead and released
the full conversations to prove that you
know he wasn't doing anything untoward
with underage girls
it doesn't really clear him from I mean
that story that you just told doesn't
even involve anybody underage it's just
him kind of being creepy in general but
you know um as far as the stuff of
targeting or trying to meet up with
girls underage or whatever he's pretty
much exempt from what I can tell he's
exonerate himself on that so you know
nothing actually illegal but that
doesn't mean it's cool it's just he's
not gonna get arrested for it I guess
you know so I mean that's pretty strange
to be like hey my buddy's gonna come to
you get his dick sucked he it's like a
sex trafficking right the worst one that
I've read well then there's the other
story that the LA Times covered was
D'Elia apparently had a pet this is from
the same article get a pattern of
quickly taking his relationships with
fans to sexual places 2015 he performed
in New York and then the score Laura the
19 a female friend who was 21 then
approached Aaliyah after set to request
photographs with them he obliged and
invited the pair to a party at his New
York City hotel they came to the hotel
they made the hour-long drive but when
they arrived they were surprised to find
him alone we looked at each other
low-key because no one was there there
was shrimp scampi on the counter and he
was watching cops but there was no sign
of a party but I was so not even excited
to be there I didn't even really see an
issue before they could enter the room
D'Elia told the woman he needed to take
their cell phones and leave them
a basket well I just assumed it was
something that anybody with that level
of fame did I gotta start doing that I
guess I'm not as famous I'm not meeting
anyone yeah and I don't mean anyone I
think he I got to take your phone ela he
told us is for privacy reasons they said
that Delia offered them alcoholic drinks
he has long maintained he does not
consume alcohol that's interesting and
you know what saying he's got all those
bits about drunk girls still know it's
like dude you're an expert for drunk
drunk girls when it doesn't drink it's
at between them on the couch it began
complimenting them and groping their
buttocks they allege growing
increasingly uncomfortable the french
tôle awkward glances at each other I
didn't know where his hands were gonna
go she said we realized no one else was
coming he wasn't drinking he was just
saying she and I should drink so we
ended up getting up to leave but as they
started to gather the things both women
say he pulled down his sweatpants pulled
out his erect penis and asked are you
sure about that they grabbed their
phones and exited the room later telling
a male friend who had attended the show
with them about the encounter their
friend confirmed this with the times so
I mean those both stories are pretty
freaking weird
yeah it's like sexual deviancy for sure
so that's I mean like I mean I'm
disappointed dude I just don't know why
man like can like he has a sex addiction
just get help and like it's just it's
sad that he threw away this incredible
career because he just he has he had
this issue that he apparently I mean he
had to have known that what he was doing
was dangerous and wrong unless in denial
about it it could be that he justify it
by saying hey they're all overage I mean
in his statement that he made to TMZ or
whatever I mean he did say that he was
in the wrong and took responsibility and
got out of control or whatever so I mean
certainly now he's aware though is there
any he's had a huge growth in the past
three years has there been any evidence
come out that he's done anything like
this in the past three years I mean is
he actually attempting to reform himself
and it's just coming out now
it might be I think what happened is his
role in to show you is what made like I
think the first one that came out she
was like I saw him play this role in the
show and he was like what the [ __ ]
that's what he did to me
and that's why she wrote oh dude
so I think it's quite possible he's
attempted to reform himself in the past
several years knowing that what he was
doing was wrong but ultimately I don't
know that yeah I don't know that yeah
but it's see I I don't recall seeing any
allegations for coming from the past
several years I could be totally I mean
I just searched the LA Times article and
yeah 2017 is seems to be the most recent
one at least that they talked about in
here so just feel bad for everyone
involved it's like to come on I just sat
I was like bro seriously what the [ __ ]
so what do you think I mean it my mind
of course goes to the similarities with
the louis c.k situation and he's like
attempting a comeback with his career or
whatever do you think D'Elia will in a
couple years we'll be able to come back
or is he just he's done I was wondering
about how it compares to the louis c.k
thing Louie CK that apparently was
receiving consult I always hear
conflicting things people he says he got
consent to everyone he jerked off in
front of but then I also heard that he
would stand in front of a door and pull
his dick out before anyone gave him
consent so I'm still confused on exactly
what went down the thing about just
standing in front of a door is like kind
of super rapey some weird so but I
forget like I don't know what happened
so my facts are not straight on the Lucy
case I think um I think Louie's apology
was like I mean you got a lot of respect
for his like just straight up owing like
he just Louie I think is the only person
to ever go through like this level of
cancelling and just straight out come
out and [ __ ] like own everything
I mean yeah sort of
still waiting to see what exactly kind
of comeback his wanting what's already
sort have been happening well he's not
gonna get back to the level that he was
at he has a lot of fans but no but I
mean like when it happened he made it
release where he's like it's all true I
did that [ __ ] I'm sick that wasn't I
need help right and I was and I think I
found that really refreshing to see
somebody be like you know owning it yeah
at the same time Louie I mean first of
all it's honestly it's shocking to see
someone jerk off but Kris is like I feel
like I feel like it takes time to
process these things like I'm still
trying to really process what happened
with grace cuz at first it was dis
stories and then I heard those just the
last two stories we just talked about
which really sound awful to me and in
his case I do think it's involving young
girls maybe on their age yeah that feels
worse that makes it really bad and that
he's having sex with them like seeing
some a jerk off is shocking and and it
could be traumatic but I think like the
intimacy of sex is probably honestly
they're both bad yeah they both they're
both they're both tough or not what am i
what am i comparing uh the Holocaust to
the Armenian Genocide over here except
let's let's tone it down anything not
quite as bad nobody dies but the point
is that you know why are we comparing
them yeah it's all sad but I have a
happy ending
I break in tensional II was like this
episode's gonna be heavy but I'm gonna
have I'm gonna end it with something
awesome are you ready this guy Theo
shan't tonus I'm such a ade illiterate
idiot I think I said it right though
Theo Shan tonus that's right on Twitter
he posted what I think is the greatest
video ever
watching this last night and I was like
this is the best video ever so follow
him and watch this
he said lockdown has provided important
research time for science
did you watch this ela oh yeah there you
go so he's on a treadmill in a laundry
basket and he speeds it up by 1 mile per
hour every time and he's trying to stick
the landing
I think it's faster faster and it just
gets so crazy this one he actually
camped out is some cool running [ __ ]
this one he I love them you know I love
that like seven miles per hour he sticks
that [ __ ] like it's all it's the fan
[Laughter]
this guy forgiving us all laugh today at
Theo Shan tonus god bless him I think
that obviously that's the end of our
episode but I just do want to emphasize
again what I said in the beginning is
that these people are all real people I
just I feel bad for everybody you know
just try to be just try to be a little
tender when dealing with the people here
that it's just I know how bad it feels
to be on the receiving end of all this
and you know just remember that they are
real people I do really want to impart
that and you may say I'm a hypocrite
because I you'd and that's fine I'm a
hypocrite everybody knows that the a
just stands for hypocrite you're a
[ __ ] hypocrite well come on who are
you two talking sir you are a piece of
[ __ ] garbage wait hold on kids are
you really in a place to call me garbage
good luck Ethan because your
[ __ ] eat it what are you threatening
me no you really crossed the line I
crossed the line you just threatened me
garbage you're garbage garbage garbage
you know what
keemstar let's be cool I think we should
be cool and just bury the hatchet how
dare you say that garbage the [ __ ] what
do you think about ela garbage dare you
what do you think about Dan garbage how
dare you what about Ian garbage what
about Zack garbage damn it's
cold-blooded now there is this one clip
what do you think about okay seriously
keemstar just be straight with me what
do you think about roses garbage pizza
garbage puppies garbage what really tins
garbage love is love love is love
garbage what love is loved keep star
what do you think about help me out here
let's end it this podcast garbage mm-hmm
I'll agree with that one and you got it
right on that case garbage garbage Oh
God anyway guys thank you for joining us
today on what can only be described as
the most tea filled
Earl black Earl black black girl there's
a lot of my line Earl Grey tea like the
greasy really fit tea you know
and done you don't know what greasy t
like when you had a cup I swear to god
it's disgusting Earl Grey is greasy it's
so thick I don't know whatever I've been
drinking there's like grease on the top
I swear to God every time
can I just pieced out on a real gray
okay it's basically like tea that's
coffee I'm like I'll just have coffee
Earl who's Earl anyway idiot yes
[ __ ] Earl is what I want to say here
today hey Kim sir what do you think
about Earl Grey coffee guard baby agree
on that do you think Kim sir do you
prefer the grease on the top of your
Earl Grey garbage yeah I don't like it
either so we agree on that now there is
this one clip well hold out though well
hold on though sometimes I do like Earl
Grey with a little cream in it you're a
[ __ ] hypocrite I'm sorry but I just
if you put cream in it it really makes
it okay you're a [ __ ] hypocrite well
we disagree on that I guess garbage
alright guys we'll see you next week
what can I say Oh Hamilton is out I'm so
excited that Hamilton film on Disney
plus I'm a closeted Hamilton on [ __ ] I
just lost all my stoop credibility is
just like really obsessed with it I
think it's a really I know I don't know
why I'm sorry
Allah gets mad because I like Hamilton
not because you just like it because
you're obsessed sorry for caring about
something it can listen to the Elven
like seven days a week it's been a lot
less there was a time less lately I'll
admit except this five million well I
took a dog morning your walk I woke I
woke up at 5:00 a.m. I had to take a
dump it was just awful because it was
like disruptive but I was like I was all
hyped to watch Hamilton
a day that I didn't realize that like
the door was open and you know I was
waking way too much noise for sure and I
apologize I hear like woke up at 5:00
a.m. to hear
Hamilton playing anything using like the
todo and I hear like the air dryer no I
didn't use the air dress I was squirting
sent me a message turn it down and then
it stopped completely like when mom and
dad scream at you so do you not be day
anymore no I shared the bidet going
crazy because yeah the pulsate and the
oscillate so it's going nah just power
wash you seen paddle watching porn power
wash porn know that it's a subreddit
where they like something dirty and then
you power wash it and it's like so clean
that's what the todo is power watch for
the [ __ ] Wendy Williams that is so
inappropriate
that is Wendy Williams busting ass
that's the real soundbite go ahead Zack
you can smell it I'm so hungry
Mexican food right
keep going Zack you making me hungry
yeah all right all right guys have a
great terrific weekend we love you we
appreciate you and we will be seeing you
next week here on the h3 hypocrite 3
hypocrite
3 podcast
[Music]
[Music]